Pomp and ceremony for the two-day
meeting in Accra but the credibility of
West African Regional block ecowas is on
the line defense Chiefs from across the
region are focused on a potential
so-called Last Resort military solution
against coup leaders in Niger let no one
be in doubt that if everything has faith
the billion forces
of West Africa both the military and the
civilian components are ready
to answer to the Call of Duty diplomatic
efforts by numerous delegations
including ecowas the African Union Chad
the UN and the U.S all bids to find a
peaceful solution to the crisis have so
far failed
the military leaders of the coup in
Niger have formed what they say as a
transitional government and not only are
they still refusing to free detained
democratically elected president
Muhammad bahrazum but they are now
putting him on trial for treason
a move Echo us and many in the
International Community say blatantly
contradicts the junta's pledge to find a
peaceful solution to the crisis
in Niger echoas sanctions and the
suspension of international humanitarian
Aid is beginning to bite and it's the
people many of whom support the coup who
are suffering the most
we fled in security to come here we're
tired some days I find food other days I
don't find food some days they can work
and other days I can't
some analysts say there is no Unity
among ecos member states on how best to
respond now you are hearing across the
region particularly from the parliament
from the people and even from some
member State notably from Cape Verde
which is the leading Democratic state
that they are opposed to any use of
military force so this is a project that
is no longer consensual
this Unity amongst West African States
political opposition within them the
danger of potentially causing a wider
Regional War and the risk of giving
armed groups like Al-Qaeda and isil the
opportunity to take advantage and launch
more attacks despite these dangers it
seems that West African defense Chiefs
are far from taking the military option
off the table yet
Accra